[Music]
what i specifically want to talk to you
about this afternoon
is connecting properly
with the environments within which we
live
and i believe and and in many ways the
lockdown uh in britain and in other
countries that we've all experienced
uh since the beginning of the
coronavirus pandemic
has only sharpened my conviction that
um the most expensive
engagement with place and space
that we can have consists
in re-engaging with what is right in
front of us
and around us
for about 10 years now i've been
teaching a course called
psychogeography uh at brunel university
before that for some years i i wrote a
weekly newspaper column in
in the independent called
psychogeography
i think it's it's become a term that
people think they understand and think
they know about
but perhaps it needs a little bit of a
clarification
in order for me to get across to you how
i believe the practice of
psychogeography
and it is a practice it's not really an
academic field
uh can assist you not in a kind of
low-level touchy-feely mindfulness way
i'm not interested in trying to you know
i i tend to follow
that the great russian writers view uh
turganyev's view when he talked about
eastern mysticism and and said what's
the difference between a white void
and a black void which is not to knock
eastern mysticism
uh it's just that i'm not concerned to
help people to in some ways zone out
or lose a sense of their individuality
and their subjectivity altogether
well i'm much more interested in and i
can see this does bear some
relationships to kind of modish
mindfulness
is an intense actualization of
subjectivity
followed by its release and in that
act kind of the as it were existential
act of the abandonment of subjectivity
to paradoxically experience one's
freedom in a world that it seems
increasingly chaotic uh and uh
to to to offer little wiggle room for
genuine autonomy
uh for all sorts of reasons and for all
sorts of people so
psycho geography gida board the french
situationist uh said that the
the the term was uh formulated by an
illiterate kabil
or north african a somewhat uh
tendentious observation
uh but at any rate it became current
in these kind of art revolutionary
circles in the paris
of uh the mid to late 1950s and then
into the 1960s
and psycho geography was
was viewed by these people who were
marxists of a sort though rather
heterodox
as a minute examination of the effects
of place and space
on the psyche a kind of attunement to
place in space
uh in this they were following andre
breton's surrealist
group who you know also had ideas about
the great
value of a certain kind of if you like
uh conscious flannery a certain kind of
wandering through urban spaces and
places
that is informed by a certain kind of
sensibility
following on from the surrealists the
situationists
took up this idea of flannery which
in its way goes back to to baudelaire
and his great essay the painter of
modern life and to the kind of paris
arcades of the uh 1820s and 30s
and enlarged it into a kind of
philosophy of life
a kind of philosophy of radical autonomy
for the situationists the technique they
were happiest to employ
was what they called the dech reeve or
drift
and so the idea of the de leave or drift
is simply that you
abandon your normal preoccupations
you're kind of
you give up trying to work life balance
and you simply move forward
uh into life uh into into the
environment without some kind of
calculation of what i tend to
to say to my students is a kind of
metric formulated by time and money
and and i think under in the kind of
environments and
economies within which we live and work
a great problem is that all of our
journeys at least heretofore often to
up until the pandemic uh involved
just such a calculation really every one
of us is like a kind of
little cab driver who is um
you know got a meter internal to your
psyche that is constantly calculating
the time involved from get to getting
from a to b
the money involved and whether the
journey is worthwhile and
i'd say this applies even to kind of
leisure travel
or visiting friends or relations it all
becomes
factored into the overall metric of time
and money
so the derive is to chuck out that
on board meter we're all suffering from
uh and instead to try
in as far as it's possible i think this
is the very essence of the derived
to move through the environment with no
preconceptions
no destinations it is the true idea that
it's about the journey
uh not what's at the end of it it's
actually surprisingly hard to do for
people
uh to decouple in that way we think we
can do it
uh but we find it incredibly hard you
know one of the things that of course i
have to say to students from the get-go
is you're not going to be looking at
your phone
you're certainly not going to be
consulting the gps
navigation program on your phone the
great problem with that
of course is that it's almost
antithetical to what i want to talk
about
gps gives you absolute location
but no orientation whatsoever it reduces
everything to the compass of your screen
and of course since the inception of uh
fully bidirectional digital media in the
early 2000s you've increasingly seen
people wandering around cities
who uh you know are just looking at the
screen in front of them as if it were a
breviary
or a salter of some kind and they were
added
of some strange religion so
you know you've got to leave the mobile
phone at home
and you've got to abandon the idea of a
destination and you have to move through
the environment
being drawn by inclinations what looks
interesting
uh what leads you on where have you
never been before
uh is there a chance encounter that will
divert you from your route and
and again you know you might think well
that sounds
fairly easy to do but but it it's
surprisingly difficult
if you like it's a kind of free
association of place and space it's a
kind of engagement with the environment
that is predicated on treating places
and spaces
as if they were a kind of repressed
content that comes to the surface
of your psyche and it's puts me in mind
actually of my late mentor jg ballard
and his novel crash in which he tried to
create an
environment that was the inversion
of the latent and the manifest in the
idea of the freudian dream content
so for freud there's the manifest
content of the dream
you know i was eating an enormous
marshmallow and then i was sick
and then there's the latent content it's
to do with your castration
anxiety or your whatever it is it's to
do with some buried complex
ballard inverts that for many of its
novels and in a way the process of
psychogeography in the derive
is to undertake a similar inversion to
start regarding
environments as sites of repression
that need to be unlocked in some way or
other uh the colleague i teach
uh the course at brunell at nick
papadimitri
is a believer in what he calls deep
topography as an offshoot from psycho
geography and this is the idea
that there are actual kind of
wellsprings of collective memory a kind
of
you know interlinkage between the yugian
collective
uh unconscious and the environment such
that you know a particular manhole cover
or
electricity substation or granolithic
post is in fact a wellspring that you
can unlock and you can tap in
to these uh collective memories or
indeed you can think about another
psycho geographer though he doesn't like
the term applied to him such as ian
sinclair
whose books take the form of
a recorded and re-enacted literary
derive
and in which he himself believes that he
is being driven
either endeavor by magical currents
such as ley lines for example that run
beneath our ordinary perception of the
environments
through which we move listen i'm not
opposed to any of these mystical or
occultist ideas
but actually in terms of the primary act
of the derive the primary act of trying
simply to
move through environments on a random
basis
they seem to me really obvious
stratagems rather than actually
containing any sort of metaphysical
ideas
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you